más económica y fácil de distribuir que
las vacunas rivales se espera que la
vacuna contra el kobe 19 desarrollada
por astrazéneca cambie las reglas del
juego en un país que ha reportado más de
10 millones de casos el panel asesor de
medicamentos de india aprobó el fármaco
para uso de emergencia se convierte así
en el tercer país en hacerlo reino unido
y argentina lo hicieron a principios de
semana las autoridades quieren comenzar
la vacunación de manera inminente
esperar inocular a 300 millones de sus
1350 millones de habitantes en los
primeros 6 a 8 meses del año
desarrollada por astrazéneca y la
universidad de oxford es el serum
institute el que fabrica la vacuna en el
país ya ha almacenado alrededor de 50
millones de dosis
sigue habiendo preguntas sobre su
eficacia y datos que muestran una
divergencia en las tasas de éxito aunque
en general los estudios muestran que
ofrece una efectividad del 70 por ciento
se puede almacenar a temperaturas
refrigeradas normales lo que es
particularmente importante para las
naciones con una infraestructura
sanitaria menos desarrollada los
reguladores indios también están
considerando la autorización de uso
para la vacuna de facer bayón tech y
otra para la firma india bharat bayo
tech la pandemia redoblar la presión en
el país después de que las autoridades
detectar más contagios de la nueva
variante del virus surgida en reino
unido ahora rastrean a decenas de miles
de viajeros procedentes de ese país